the ones that I have been brought up
with what I think they're the best are
mainly the classical poets like helm
fair DOS e which is one of the most
wonderful poets of all times not
dispersion and the great epic poet half
is that is how we found my daughter's
name usually Persians they ask how faces
advice for everything and and when
someone is born and a lot of persons are
used to opening office to see what is
the few what the future holds for the
baby and that is how we named our
daughter it's a word from a poem by half
is roomy roomy I love hiam and then
there are the modern poets Iran at the
beginning of 20th century had not just a
political revolution which led to the
constitutional revolution and a
constitutional monarchy but also a very
radical cultural revolution and they
introduce modern poetry and prose so so
that I had I add a nema usage there's so
many the great feminist poet farakka
farakka sod so that they're there many
unfortunately
you